another imaginary problem is facing our
nation it's one frankly I can't believe
that we haven't addressed until this
point that is the name of a popular golf
tournament
I don't even can't even say this on the
air the Masters we can't you're not
allowed to say that these days
okay maybe back in the olden days when
we still had statues of George
Washington you are allowed to say that
not these days
racist this is the suggestion of Rob
Parker who's a sports columnist who
wrote this seriously
I believe it's serious it's not satire
he says we have to change the name of
the Masters in the current climate with
all the sweeping changes he writes it is
only right and just the term for the
Masters Tournament obviously does not
refer to slave owners it refers to
masters the word master has a much
longer history but the master phrase
completely disconnected from slave
owning has come under fire in other
places had happened at Yale and at
Harvard so for instance at Yale the
heads of some of the dorms that were the
residential colleges are called masters
when I when I was there I referred to my
hello master or nice to see you it ID
not because I was a slave but because
that's just the title they have it at
Oxford they have the camera that's
they've had it and a lot of different
universities they changed it it's now
head of college which depending on your
views of certain sexual slang is also
very racy so you should probably get
that one out of there too they knew that
the word master had no relationship to
slave owners just like they know that in
the golf tournament it has no
relationship to slave owners but I think
there's a flaw in their logic which is
how were they going to address one
another from now on when you call
somebody my name is Michael Knowles so
when I'm formally addressed I'm referred
to as mr. Knowles did it ever occur to
them what the word mr. means yeah
there's a verse sometimes you hear this
quoted by people who don't like that
that Catholics refer to priests as
father and they'll say we'll call no man
father
that's a verse from the Gospels that's
true but we also hear call no man
teacher and call no man master but we
refer to people as teacher and master
all the time because the word mister
means master and the word doctor means
teacher so are we gonna we're getting
rid of that huh is that it no more
misters well I think that's probably
what they want I think they just want us
all to refer to each other as comrade
from now on this has nothing to do with
race this has everything to do with a
cultural revolution with a total social
upheaval with a radical ideology all of
which has its roots in Marxism there's
been a lot of discussion in recent days
about the N word I think we need to
start talking about the M word Marxism
the founders of be LM admit that they
are quote trained Marxists on the
website it says that they have Marxist
goals they were actually on the website
refer to each other as comrades so
that's our future
what a lot of squishy conservatives are
gonna say is okay whatever change the
name no big deal I don't want to change
the title at the universities change
okay whatever well you can shrug and you
can laugh and you can pretend it's all
trivial until your entire culture is
gone until it's unrecognizable until
you're no longer allowed even to be
called by your own name this is mr.
Michael Knowles for now signing off
[Music]
[Music]